welcome to this video playing a lot Jim
again plant him a couple of times before
national mass master and bosh from the
netherlands the mastermind behind them
behind the SOS books secrets of opening
surprises we get calc on advanced
variation mmm yeah it looks like a
fairly solid a ham for black I have fun
i had developed membership to f5 to
avoid getting it trapped in the pawn
chain and um it's a very solid structure
yeah night eh for would be interesting
try to get to get this night exchanged
takes Queen takes but you can play 91
and then it looks rather silly on edge
form if I go see five he might place
here for I'm not sure that this is the
right way to play that seem some seems
wrongly timed to me this opening of the
center I think I should first complete
development interesting
well yeah he simply prevents the some
adium night h4 okay i think i'll try to
support c5 further no c 5 yeah i don't i
really cannot play it without c5 okay
yeah the night on this happen is a
problem please I I think I should spend
time reroute it so that it can go to c6
on this happen it's doing nothing
absolutely nothing and if i get to c 6 i
have fun intensified the pressure
against deform yes he needs to do that
at some stage right but i'm not sure if
it's a good here check now i can i can
play this with the check even very often
g4 night h4 white retreats the night
somewhere tries to prove that it is
offside on edge for now I was able to
exchange it yeah here we go 96 and Tim
jaundice looks fairly solid I don't
think I should have any big problems and
I can try for before but I'm not sure
that it's really so so terrible okay all
I go for okay Jade yeah at some at some
moment I must have spent lots of time
I'm far behind on the clock without
really knowing why Boyd which I had what
stage I spent so much time hmm
yeah how to play now b5 i have 9 a-5
which is not the big issue I always have
94 even as a pawn sack I cannot take
because of a three this is clear f6 may
now so that on on b5 I can play Knight
da to f7 yeah maybe it's not it's not
bad night f7 to increase per the play
against e5 oka for a fire who wants to
wants to get this into the into the mix
ok maybe take Bishop c5 who this might
lose lots of time yeah still
hmm
it's not recapturing immediately it's
that some alternative yeah maybe maybe
maybe if if I if I have a form well I
think you should just recapture
hmm
interesting i'm not i'm not sure at all
what he is thinking about okay yeah here
I thought that everything else fails I
can take on I can take 1 F 2 but
probably this isn't reasons right anyway
I can also just get the rope here and
the tech out 2nite f7 will come I think
you should just take it on c5
I could have taken on f2 Queen takes
root gauge to now he has prevented that
okay but I need to make sure not to lose
on time okay this is probably a bad move
probably it is a bad move because roop
do you want a there they are sacrifices
on d5 my king position okay okay I'll
take this chance now Queen takes rook
edge to Bishop takes rook takes
ok but what now rookie to proudly then
I'll just retreat and he can take on d5
very tricky game maybe our new glee too
should just play g5i scrubbing them
immediately but what is the threat see
threatening to make me I don't I don't
see it no I don't see it at the moment
i'll just take it and now probably a
king move somewhere or if i take take
Queen takes King e8 probably six
i'm not sure i'd like to get the king
out of out of it to be 8 download 35
seconds
I cannot go be should be through because
of group cakes
difficult position
taking me five but hard to play mmm time
morning medium I'm a dumb be some so
I can just take it check check white
forfeits on time oh yeah I generally I I
didn't really look at the time at all
and I have no idea what this position is
how to value it go on actly g6 at some
stage and this is for 146 i can probably
take it I mean I can take it anyway and
Jim gap both king song are very very
wide open probably something like this
just take it you know i can i can go
here check yeah well hard to hard to say
we both spent enormous amount of time to
around TI member sam i'm pretty sure
this looks very dangerous probably i had
my chance somewhere before maybe maybe
here yep i think black is better i'm an
exchanger but it's not clear what what
he has rock d 8 is though it's a good
one according to the computer group the
eight and possibly going to deform
something like this and now even
exchange egg exchange suck Queenie seven
champ very difficult i mean this is
basically a basically a crapshoot with
that little time on the clock I'd like
to quickly have a look a turn and this
this position
I thought you should just take yeah this
is much better I am just taking and any
move like this yeah now it's a it's a
very tricky position you can even play a
form bad piece I mean it's it's it's
fairly complicated we cannot say that
why this sir winning easily but to write
this better you played we played this
one ya missed my chance rook takes f3
then check evade this is strong yeah
this is strong exposing exposing the
king like that yeah that that's very
strong like it's just winning him ok I
went here and this is very very
dangerous he can now take on d5 yeah
very complicated game alright thanks for
watching